ahora vamos a recordar al frío de rim
con una leyenda del fútbol colombiano
que nos abandonó esta semana sin duda
han sido días de duelo para el pueblo
colombiano freddy rincón él fue un
jugador adelantado a su época jugador de
condiciones excepcionales y que manejó
esta posición del 8 del volante mixto
como hubiesen querido los técnicos de
estos tiempos jugador que mezclaba
potencia y técnica y que siempre fue
influyente en el juego y como pocos tuvo
la posibilidad de marcar goles eternos
como es el empate 11 alemania en el
mundial de italia 90 un gol que además
representado mucho para el país era el
símbolo de un estilo de juego que
también representa otra idea de nación
recuerde usted que en esa época los
únicos recuerdos o imágenes que tenía el
mundo de colombia eran los de la
violencia del narcotráfico
entonces significó mucho para el país
ese momento y sin duda es uno de esos
goles que marcaron desde brasil también
han llegado muchos actos de condolencia
porque allí encontró su lugar en el
mundo es el lugar donde supo brillar
freddy rincón sin dudas un ídolo para
todos los colombianos y una gran leyenda
del fútbol sudamericano como me decías
haga esta semana frío de rincón en este
país cada uno lo recuerdo de una manera
distinta
en especial que marcó en ese mundial de
1990 vamos